In this equation, h equals negative 3. We see h appear in two spots in the
general equation. We have a term minus 2hx, and also a term h squared. And the h
squared is going to be a little bit harder for us to pick out using this
equation. Since we have one constant term of 5 over here, but we have two
constant terms each squared and k here. And we can't tell which of these is
contributing how much to 5. However, we have one term in the general equation
that has an x to the first. And also only one term in the particular equation
that has an x to the first. So that means that we have negative 2hx is equal to
6x, just matching those terms up. To get h by itself, we just need to divide
both sides of the equation by negative 2x. Our xes will cancel out. And 6
divided by negative 2 is just negative 3. So that's our answer.